so you might already know but yesterday
i played against magnus carlsen in a
simul as part of the opening ceremony of
the syncful cup i posted a video which
you should definitely check out of the
footage of that game but in this video i
want to break down the game and share
what exactly happened what was going
through my mind all the funny lines that
could have happened and maybe some
missed opportunities as well
and the game began with an english
opening pawn to c4
which was already a small disappointment
because if he had played e4
then maybe i would go into a stafford
gambit not sure if i would pass up the
opportunity to play stafford against
magnus otb
but english opening it was and i decided
to play um just my main repertoire pawn
e6
going for a queen's gambit declined so a
small transposition
but we did transpose him to queen's
gambit and he played a very topical move
pawn takes pawn
the queen's got declined exchange
variation
and um
just a a few weeks ago i was studying
his games in this line
in preparation for some of my tournament
games in the abu dhabi masters
specifically his game against vladimir
kramnik which goes uh c6 e3 bishop f5
queen f3 and he won just a positional
masterpiece in this variation
so uh i i knew that he's uh just a pro
in this line
and a pro in general
but he actually went for a different
position after i played pawn c6 he
played queen c2
and uh this just prevents the so-called
positional line with bishop f5
and i took a small thing here deciding
which line to go for
um because the move i played in the past
is knight a6 which is kind of a tricky
sideline going for knight b4 and
sometimes g6 bishop f5
but
i opted for a different sort of offbeat
line bishop to d6
which is a variation i've been studying
recently
and
not sure if it has an official name but
i like to dub this the casa corley
variation because international master
casa corley
won
a bunch of nice games with this line and
normally the bishop doesn't go to d6
usually goes to e7 to diffuse the pin
but
this move leads to a lot of dynamic
positions where black can play for more
than just equality
so game continued magnus plays e3 i
castle
bishop d3
pawn h6 hitting the bishop he retreats
and now rook to e8
and this is all still preparation on my
part
and um here i knew that there are two
basically main moves for white so i can
play knight ge2 or knight f3 knight e2
is a bit more common after which i would
play a5
and then really hope that white castles
and then there would be a greek gift
with knight g4 to follow and there are
some other lines that after a5 white can
play h3
and um there's knight a6 a3 knight c7
there's a cool maneuver here to bring
the knight to g5 and then get the
kingside attack which is featured in
some of casa corley's games but we
didn't go quite into this because he
opted for knight to f3
and here the plan changes a little bit i
was still prepared for this i played
bishop to e6
the goal is to complete development and
get a harmonious setup with minor pieces
and there's a small trap here that if
white is a little bit too
feisty and goes for knight to e5 then
there's a really strong move pawn c5 to
just undermine white startup play knight
c6
and um yeah this is already
probably preferable for black
so he didn't play 95
i think he took a small think and
decided to castle
and then i complete development
and then he plays a3 so this is a very
typical
move for the structure uh white is going
for the minority attack
uh to eventually play b4 b5 and try and
weaken my queen side structure
so i try and slow this down with pawn a5
he plays rook ab1
and i play queen b8
and this move was essentially the last
move of my preparation
i knew that um it's a typical square for
the queen to get off the diagonal so
basically unpin the knight and also
create the battery
aimed at h2
but um
yeah with his next move he diffuses the
battery
and i go for pawn to b5 so leaving the
tension between the bishops
and b5 it's somewhat of a double-edged
move
on one hand it kind of weakens the c
pawn
because now the c pawn is backwards on
the half open file
but at the same time the the point of b5
is to get a positional
setup with eventually pawn a4
and then maneuvering the knight to c4
and if black can achieve this and it's
actually really nice because b3 would
just be restricted uh if ever b3 i would
take it and the knight would be like a
really nice outpost on the c4 square
so
he he retreats i think this is a very
fine move unleashing the queen hitting
the pawn
i trade on g3
and play queen g6 so centralizing the
queen defending the pawn
he doubles up i defend
knight f4
and now i go for a4 so trying to achieve
the dream setup
um but then he starts getting some
initiative he starts by taking the
bishop
i take back with the queen i didn't want
to take back with the pawn and just
leave the king's side a bit weaker
especially kind of this g6 square is a
gaping hole in the position
so i took with queen allowing bishop f5
move back
and then he plays 95. so
i was beginning to feel
a little bit nervous here
uh because the pressure is mounting and
i'm pinned in various directions
knight is pinned to the rook
arguably this pawn is pinned along the
sea file but the pawn is also just
attacked now three times by the knight
queen and rook
so
for a moment i thought black might be
collapsing but
i realized it's not so simple for white
after my next move rook to a7
uh just reinforcing my knight and
preparing rook c7
and even though it looks really passive
or black
it's not so easy for white to actually
crack the position
and here he took another think
and played the move queen to c3
with idea that after i double up my
rooks he plays queen to b4
offering a queen trade
but this is a very
magnus-esque move because he's trying to
get
just a slightly better end game with
queens off the board where he can grind
me down
and take advantage of the long-term
deficiency in my position
and i didn't really have any other
choice had to trade queens he takes back
with pawn
and i
in this position i took another think
and i thought i had a really clever move
in store i took the knight
leaving the rook hanging
um and then i was surprised because he
just immediately took back without even
taking time to consider
bishop takes ca at least it seemed that
way but um i thought that if he takes on
c8
this would be a really interesting
exchange sacrifice for black where i
would hop into d3 hit the rook hit the
pawn this bishop is still hanging and in
the event of rook c3 i would take the
pawn
um allowing the bishop to escape let's
say like bishop f5
and even though i'm down um a rook for
knight and pawn i think black has full
compensation because the queen side is
now really solid knight defends a pawn
and the engine actually just gives
equality in this position
so that might be why that he went for
the other move
pontigs night declining the extra
material
but keeping the pressure
now i have to move back to d7 to save
the rook
and here i'm i'm still feeling the heat
because after pawn b3 takes and takes
it's not easy to untangle like my knight
is completely stuck my rooks are tied
down at the pawn especially after white
will play rook c3 so there's not too
many options for black and i figured i
might as well improve my king i play
king to f8
he reinforces the pawn in e5 with pawn
f4 so now white's pawns are looking much
nicer i play king e7
rook c3
i kick the bishop he retreats
and now in this position i played a move
which i'm probably going to regret for
the rest of my life and i'm getting a
call right now but that was not the time
except maybe it is the time hello
hello hello okay
uh yeah that was a butt dial
oh i got butt dialed in the middle of
the video what was i saying
oh yeah in this position i played a move
which i'm probably gonna regret for the
rest of my life
and i really should have taken the
advice of ben feingold
to never play f6
but i played f6 in this position
thinking that it's a way to
just try and simplify and get rid of
this really annoying pawn on e5
and when i played this move my intention
was that after he takes back what she
did
i would play king d6
to defend the pawn essentially over
defend the pawn and then go for rook f8
and rook takes f6
and
i thought if i could achieve the setup
and then win back the pawn then i'll be
okay
but what i had missed and i realized
this right after i played f6
is that in this position white has a
really nice move pawn e4
and this is just completely winning for
white now because if i take the pawn
i get mated this is just checkmate in
the center of the board in the end game
and i'm pretty sure magnus like saw this
very quickly
and uh yeah we we got to this position
and um i had to take the pawn like this
was a only try but after i take the pawn
then
my queen side pawns crumble after takes
takes
and takes
magnus goes up upon forces the trailer
rooks
and after king to f5 he plays king f2
and i'm left with some pretty severe
pawn weaknesses and a really passive
rook against white's active rook
so i wasn't feeling so hopeful here
but then i had a really cool idea
come to mind
and in this position
i thought i had about five or six moves
and i saw a head to a potential
stalemate
and the move that i went for is pawn g5
which is upon sacrifice
he takes so now i'm down two pawns but
then i play d4
and i'm trying to get as many pawns off
the board as possible um to try and
maximize drawing chances
and the line i had calculated back when
i played g5 was if he plays rook b6
going after this pawn
i would defend
and then king f3 looks very natural to
prepare
not only a pawn check or a pawn fork but
a pawn checkmate given that my king is
completely cut off
by the rook
so if this happened i would play g4
check
force the king back take the pawn king
takes and then i would play rook to d3
check and say oh no my rook and then he
would be confused and he would take it
and then it'll be stalemate and i would
be a national hero
and there'd be articles all over the
world i'd go on the front page of reddit
but this didn't happen unfortunately and
even if this position did happen
white is still completely winning after
king f2
so
my dream and my fantasies were
not at all a reality and uh
yeah after i played g5 um he did take
and after d4 he didn't play rook b6 but
he played rook to h5
and all my dreams of stalemate kind of
just went out the window because now the
king
is not cut off and
yeah it's hard to orchestrate a stale
matrix
in this position
so i went went in with the king
he takes i take he takes
and i take
and i still had some small ounce of hope
like even though i'm down two pawns
white has three
uh pawns ready to storm down the board
i have one pawn also ready to swarm down
the board and this is essentially a race
scenario where if i can queen before him
then maybe there's some chances not to
lose
but unfortunately after rookie 5
king to d4 he plays g4
and these pawns are really really quick
and my rook is kind of tied down to my
b-pawn
so i decided here to play king to c3 to
try and control the squares my pawn can
advance to and also attack his pawn f4
and in this position magnus played a
really surprising move and when he
played this move
i thought he just overlooked my threat
he played g5
allowing me to take
the f4 pawn with check
and i went ahead and took it but after
king to g3
we can see the point that white is now
attacking the rook
and attacking my pawn
and ready to queen in just three more
moves
and yeah hope is running out the only
way to defend my rook and my pawn is
move back
he plays pawn to g6
i play king to d4 he plays rook g5
and
i was trying to come up with any sort of
last trick but i realized
i'm playing magnus carlsen
he's about to queen so i threw in the
towel
and resigned
and we shook hands
and as the game was finishing he was
just like signing autographs uh because
there's so many kids around that wanted
his his signature and photos with him so
it's kind of a funny finish to the game
but yeah it was uh it was a cool
experience to play uh the greatest chess
player
of all time arguably
it was different than playing an actual
goat in chess
magnus is a really good player and
yeah in this game he he played like
magnus carlsen so what to do
but i hope you enjoyed the video and uh
yeah and stay tuned for more content i'm
hoping there will be more content
opportunities with some top players so
stay tuned and i'll see you guys soon